[Music]
November 30th 1989 just after 3 A.M New
York City Janet Kimball was driving over
the Brooklyn Bridge when her car stalled
and slowly rolled to a stop after a
couple of failed attempts to get the car
started Janet was hit by a bright light
bright enough that she had to Shield her
eyes the light was coming from an
apartment building Janet thought maybe
someone was shooting a movie Not Unusual
in New York City then she saw that the
light was coming from a saucer-shaped
craft hovering above the building
okay it's a science fiction movie Janet
thought but it wasn't a movie this was
happening for real as Janet's eyes
adjusted to the brightness she saw
something levitating in the light
objects floating up to the saucer when
she focused she realized they weren't
objects they were people well one of
them was in an instant the light went
out and the saucer plunged into the East
River there were 23 eyewitnesses to this
event including one of the highest
ranking politicians in the world and
people being transported to a UFO by a
beam of light in the middle of New York
City that's not the weirdest part of the
story
foreign
November 30th 1989 just after 3 A.M New
York City as Linda Napolitano was
falling asleep she felt a strange
numbness in her feet that started to
creep up her legs she opened her eyes
and standing at the foot of her bed was
a small pale humanoid creature with a
large round head and big black eyes from
behind the curtains another creature
emerged and then another four or five of
these beings slowly and silently walked
toward her bed Linda screamed for her
husband lying right next to her but he
didn't wake up the numbness reached her
neck and she couldn't move she made
another attempt to scream but then she
heard a voice in Her Mind say be quiet
then Linda felt herself levitating above
the bed she slowly floated from the
bedroom to the living room the creature
is silently walking beside her then she
floated through a window and threw the
safety bars on the outside of the window
she was then hovering outside her
apartment 12 stories up she remembers
thinking oh my God I hope I don't fall
she was surrounded by a bright white
blue light the other creatures were also
floating in the light slowly they all
ascended into the saucer-shaped craft
once inside the ship the humanoid
creatures escorted Linda down a hallway
that was lined with benches as they
passed various rooms she heard the hiss
of doors sliding open and closing again
the creatures were quietly talking to
each other but they were speaking a
language Linda didn't understand finally
they bring Linda to a bright room and in
the center of the room is a long table
oh no the dreaded long table this sent
Linda into a panic and she started
screaming in her mind she was screaming
what do you want from me but the words
that came out of her mouth were in an
alien language one of the beings put a
hand over Linda's mouth then she felt
something in her nose a long medical
instrument was forced into her right
nostril you know as far as alien probes
go a nostril
the worst option that that's a good
point one of the creatures then moved
very close to Linda and gently ran its
hand through her hair and placed a warm
hand on her cheek she asked him why am I
here he said just for a visit instantly
Linda was able to move she sat up on the
table heard a loud roar and then she was
sitting up in her bed she tried to wake
her husband Steve but he wasn't moving
then a wave of panic washed over her her
children she bolted down the hall and
into the bedroom shared by her two young
Sons she called them but they didn't
respond she grabbed Johnny her youngest
she was sobbing as she shook him he
didn't wake up
in the art World Bud Hopkins was a big
deal his art is part of the permanent
collections of the Guggenheim the
Whitney the met the Museum of Modern Art
and the British Museum and a few others
yeah this is his art yeah are you sure
he's weren't made by some kid in third
grade yeah I'm sure he's a world famous
artist yeah I don't get it anybody could
do this what do you know about art you
know I happen to be the proud owner of
fish playing poker don't you mean dogs
playing poker
what the hell are you talking about
forget it
Bud Hopkins was not just a well-known
artist he also made a name for himself
as a UFO investigator he was one of the
leading experts on alien abduction
experiences he investigated hundreds of
cases he wrote several books including
the best seller Intruders and missing
time he even hosted support groups in
his home for Witnesses and survivors
okay you are Mio but this guy sounds all
right he was a good guy he was well
respected and well liked and everyone
who knew him said he was kind
compassionate and intelligent because of
his reputation and open door policy he
got a lot of mail but a letter he
received in February 1991 stood out from
the others Dear Mr Hawkins my partner
and I are police officers we've been in
a serious dilemma because of a strict
profession and our lack of knowledge on
this subject about 3 30 a.m in late
November 1989 we sat in our patrol car
underneath the elevated FDR Drive there
it was a strange oval hovering over the
top of an apartment building two or
three blocks from where we were sitting
a very bright blue light coming from the
bottom of it I yell for my partner who
is just as excited as I was we were
going to get out of the car but what can
we do for that poor little girl or a
woman wearing the full white nightgown
she was cloaking midair in a bright beam
a whitish blue light looking like an
angel she was then brought up into the
bottom of that very large oval about
three quarters the size of the building
across his poor person was escorted out
of a window by three ugly but smaller
human-like creatures after it she was up
and in the oval plunged into the river
not far from the Brooklyn Bridge Mr
Huffington's the oval never came up from
under the river the guilt has lingered
and we find it difficult living with
ourselves a partner and I have been
dating if we should seek her out we know
the building and we know the window
perhaps she was just a figment of our
imagination if she isn't is she alive
and well we have to know if we should
decide to seat this personnel we'll
contact you again with further
information if we do find that and I
hope we do many thanks police officers
Dan and Richard
Bud Hopkins was amazed he knew the woman
referenced in the letter she'd been
coming to his support groups it was
Linda Napolitano this was the first time
but Hopkins had accounts of the same
event from different people about two
weeks later Linda called she was
agitated she had just had a visit from
two police detectives named Richard and
Dan the visit was strange
foreign
it was almost 11 at night when Linda
heard the knock on her door through the
peephole she saw two men dressed in dark
suits they showed her badges and
announced themselves as detectives she
let them in it was Richard and Dan the
men who sent the letter to Bud Hopkins
Linda said Dan was a bit standoffish and
distant but Richard was very nice if a
bit nervous at some point during their
30-minute conversation Richard almost
broke down in tears Linda retold her
experience and how her husband and
children were put into such a deep sleep
that she couldn't wake them up for a few
hours she actually put a mirror under
her son's nose to make sure he was alive
he had us looking up a kid's nose prove
he's alive
what was she checking for booger mortis
no not booger mortis she was checking to
see if he fogged a mirror ah that makes
more sense Linda asked Richard and Dan
to call Bud Hopkins but they said they
weren't comfortable doing that the men
left and Linda thought that was the end
of it then Bud Hopkins received another
letter dear bud we're hoping that this
audio tape is satisfactory we don't know
how well but use it as you wish we'll
keep in touch thanks Dan and Richard P.S
Linda is a darling little lady
along with the letter was a cassette
tape the recording was Richard alone the
tape begins mid-sentence
you know your feelings on the whole
matter I understand
as far as the state is concerned I've
written everything down so that'll be
easier to express on tape please excuse
my reading voice the subject matter was
the strangest ever in my life work
Linda is a nice person we saw it through
all the discomfort she felt Lindy
expressed the Deep importance of our
reaching you and to actually see it now
and speaking with her we could see just
how frightened and sincere she was when
we saw actually happened and I hope that
it doesn't drive me nuts Richard went on
to recap the events of the night Linda
was taken even though Richard didn't
want to publicly confirm the story he
thought an audio recording would be
useful to Bud we'll never forget the
look on her face pure white with no
expression a white Mommy doll hanging in
the air with my binoculars I could see
three of the ugliest creatures I ever
saw I don't know what they were they
weren't human the heads were all out of
proportion with no air the eyes were
very large very large eyes those buggers
were escorting her into the craft
thank you bud for keeping her good hands
I don't know what you're going to do
with this tape but I do know it's all I
can do for you bud Belinda and all the
other people like her please respect the
importance of our credibility of work we
just can't be identified will we be
laughed at thank you bud
Richard and Dan were struggling to
process what they saw Richard was doing
okay but Dan his sanity began to unravel
[Music]
a few weeks after Bud Hopkins received
the audio tape from Richard he received
a letter from Dan Dear Mr Hopkins my
name is Danny you are acquainted with my
partner Richard I decided to get in
touch with you after a long fishing trip
fishing trip oh I don't like this guy at
all but be quiet and let the man talk
I'm not depressed anymore because
Linda's alive however anger fear and
embarrassment set in Richard is dealing
with these very same feelings in his own
way he remedies it by secretly watching
Linda I don't think she would like to
know that seeing window reinforces the
reality of it all and he doesn't feel
crazy anymore this doesn't work for me
when I see Linda I tremble I don't need
reminders I'll never forget what
happened for the rest of my life now
Linda did say she saw a white van parked
near her building and she felt like she
was being followed and watched that
November incident was the worst time of
my life see the UFO wasn't enough we had
to see some young woman being taken what
were they gonna do to her what could I
do to help her these thoughts were more
than I could take it did Richard tell
you about our nightmares Mr Hopkins I
sleep with my pistol beside my bed if
they could take Linda they could take me
Richie has the same fear we understand
that you need us to come forward because
these people youers are considered crazy
we know they aren't crazy but to be
honest with you you're going to need
more of the True Detectives to figure
out what the hell has been happening to
a lot of people good luck in your
investigations if you ever stumble upon
good tangible evidence be careful whom
you give it to there's an obvious
cover-up going on thanks for taking the
time to read this very long letter
sincerely Danny this is when Bud Hopkins
decided that he had to track down
Richard and Dan he went to precincts all
over the city and put up Flyers no cops
came forward but that's not surprising
because Richard and Dan they weren't
cops
foreign
Hopkins didn't tell Linda that Richard
and Dan lied about being detectives he
wanted to wait and see what else he
could find out a few weeks later bud
received another letter
Dear Mr Hopkins we're writing to you
once again because of the utmost
importance of what has to be said there
is much more involved we were given
permission to reveal more facts from a
third party also involved in the
November 1989 incident this third party
is a very important person and often
speaks to many corners of the globe
eventually we learned that this third
witness is Javier Perez de Cuellar the
Secretary General of the United Nations
he's one of the highest profile and most
important political officials in the
world Richard and Dan were working as a
security detail for the Secretary
General driving him to the heliport
downtown when they got close to Linda's
building their car died then the three
of them saw everything that happened the
cuer said that under no circumstances he
to be identified so Richard and Dan
pretended to be cops Secretary General
de Cuellar was happy to hear that Linda
was safe but he wanted no more to do
with this Richard and Dan however
continued to struggle emotionally a few
weeks later later on April 29 1991 Linda
was on her way to the supermarket when
she heard someone call her name she
turned and saw Richard they made small
talk then Richard pointed to a black
luxury car parked nearby its rear door
open he asked Linda to take a ride so
they can talk Linda said she had too
many errands to run but Richard was
welcome to come to her apartment later
that evening to talk Richard said he
couldn't do that and asked her to
reconsider Linda apologized again and
renewed the invitation for Richard to
come by later then Richard's face turned
dark and he grabbed her Dan jumped out
of the car and said come on cutie he's
got you they shoved her into the car and
Richard held her down while Dan jumped
in the driver's seat then the car tore
away from the curb and disappeared into
traffic
foreign
Richard and Dan interrogated Linda they
demanded to know who she was working for
if she was working for the government
any government if she was working for
the aliens Linda denied all of this
through sobs then Dan got angry and told
her to stop crying and he said you're
one of them aren't you he thought she
was an alien she denied this too then
Dan started to get really angry he
pulled into a rest stop Dan demanded
that she'd take off her shoes so he
could examine her feet and what is this
Force Podiatry Just go with it it'll
make sense later okay they want to see
your feet go on though she feels
ridiculous Linda complies and shows them
her feet she knew that if she didn't do
this willingly they would just force her
for almost four hours they drove around
and asked Linda questions who were the
aliens where did they come from what did
they do when they took her where did
they go she answered again and again
that she was only partly conscious and
couldn't remember anything finally they
dropped her off at her building Richard
apologized but Linda said she never
wanted to see them again to try and get
more details but Hopkins conducted a
hypnosis session with Linda they learned
that the car was a Rolls-Royce it had a
blue United Nations sticker and
diplomatic plates and there was a second
car that followed them a Mercedes Linda
was able to remember a couple of numbers
from the plate using this information
and calling in a favor from a friend Bud
Hopkins confirmed that the Rolls-Royce
belonged to the Secretary General a few
weeks later Linda heard her name called
again it was Richard she ran he chased
eventually she was able to get away from
him and into her apartment building a
few months went by without incident but
then Bud Hopkins received another letter
from Dan and if you thought this story
was wild before
[Music]
September 17 1991. dear bud I hope this
letter finds you in good health and
happy Spirits much has happened since
I've last contacted you Dan apologized
for what they did to Linda he said
there's no excuse but he and Richard are
under a tremendous amount of stress it
turned out that Richard Dan and
Secretary General de Cuellar had a
shared memory that was triggered by the
events of the past few months after the
UFO plunged into the river the three men
suddenly found themselves on a beach
nearby they saw Linda and three aliens
digging in the sand they could hear them
speaking a foreign language in alien
language Linda and the aliens then
walked up to the men Linda's face was
blank but she held up a dead fish and
yelled at them look and see what you've
done then one of the beings said Lady of
the Sands the men noticed the aliens had
no toes told you I do respect her for
sticking up for that fish though that
was solid Linda and the aliens then
walked toward the water and suddenly
Richard Dan and decoyar were back near
their car though the Secretary General
was on the roof of the car Dan and
Richard helped him down
um uh you're making this up nope this
was all witnessed by multiple people
in the letter Dan gets annoyed when we
questioned Glinda last April we knew she
was withholding information perhaps she
was frightened and didn't know what our
intentions were the fact remains we
still don't know who she is we will let
to believe that she is the Lady of the
Sands whatever that is whatever the case
we need to know who she is as for me
Linda is a pain in the rump I dislike
admitting that she could fly to the moon
in her spacecraft and the distance
wouldn't be far enough as far as I'm
concerned on a good day I think about
having a heart-to-heart talk with Linda
Linda would never consent to such a
meeting but we will meet in the near
future
Linda says she is indifferent but she is
different and I'm gonna find out the
difference if you can prepare Linda for
a visit from me I don't want to run it
off again please start trying to find us
and please tell Linda we honestly didn't
kill that fish thank you bud Danny so
Bud Hypnotized Linda again to see if she
could remember any of this did she
remember she did all of it she said they
were taking samples of the sand to see
if they could figure out why the fish
were dying she also remembered being
called Lady of the Sands but she had no
idea what that meant Bud then read her
Dan's letter that said he would be
coming for her and on October 15th in
broad daylight Dan grabbed her and
shoved her into his car this time he was
alone and he was out of his mind
Dan drove for a while and then pulled
the car over he whispered to Linda come
here half breed then kissed her all over
his face ugh this guy yeah he's gross
they kept driving and periodically he
would grab her knee she would resist and
he would say things like oh you're a
tough one they eventually arrived at a
beach house on Long Island by now Linda
stopped resisting she figured whatever
Dan wanted to happen was just gonna
happen and resisting would just make it
worse always resist ladies yeah give
yourself a fighting chance plus bruises
scratches and other evidence can help
find the perp anyway when they got into
the house Dan kissed her all over her
face again he told her to make herself
at home and he went to the kitchen to
make coffee she looked for a phone there
wasn't one she looked for some
identifying information so she could
learn Dan's last name there was nothing
there were two pictures framed one was
of Linda kissing her son Johnny goodbye
the other picture was of Linda by a
lighthouse Dan returned from the kitchen
carrying a white gift wrapped box Linda
open inside was a negligee oh no yeah he
told her to put it on she refused she
could see the anger in Dan's eyes so
Linda offered to put it on over her
clothes Dan agreed Dan then goes white
and says oh my God it was you Dan then
dropped to his knees and started crying
Linda gently put a hand on his shoulder
and then she bolted for the door and out
onto the beach get a girl she ran as
fast as she could she could hear Dan
screaming behind her and he was getting
closer finally he grabbed her and
instead of hurting her he started gently
rocking her back and forth he said isn't
this nice we'll go far away and make a
new family Linda said she didn't want a
new family Dan snapped he shoved Linda's
face into the sand and yelled dig more
holes Lady of the Sands he tried to kiss
her he grabbed her clothes Linda
screamed for help but the beach was
deserted finally Dan yanked Linda to her
feet and said let's clean your face he
dragged her by her hair and shoved her
head under the water
Linda blacked out
Dan held Linda underwater but luckily
the undertow grabbed her and helped her
to break free she crawled back onto the
beach but she was so exhausted that she
didn't care what happened to her but Dan
didn't try to drown her again instead he
sat next to her cradled her in his arms
and rocked her back and forth again
yikes this guy's a few fries she would
have a Happy Meal oh yeah he's lost it
but then Linda turns around and standing
in the doorway of the beach house is
Richard Richard yelled for Dan to get
off her then help them into the house he
calmed in down and persuaded him to go
upstairs and get cleaned up once
everything was calm Richard took Linda
home a few days later but Hopkins
receives a letter from Richard Dear Mr
Hopkins I was angered and saddened about
the whole incident that took place on
October 15th concerning Linda and Dan
Linda is very special to me and Dan is
my closest friend but I want my friend
back but he just isn't the same Richard
also included a couple of pictures that
Dan took of Linda while she was running
on the beach and in this letter Richard
explained that Dan was getting
psychiatric help what had driven Dan
over the edge was the fact that Linda
had been speaking to them telepathically
what but when Dan and Richard grabbed
her off the street the first time she
said to them telepathically be kind
don't hurt me this was very unsettling
for Dan oh but this Richard guide
doesn't find that weird no because when
they were on the beach with the aliens
Richard telepathically told Linda how
much he loved her and she telepathically
returned his feelings oh it is romance
now if that's what you want to call it
well you told me this story had
everything and boy howdy you weren't
just Whistling Dixie told ya she is kind
in giving does Linda have this effect on
others are we the unusual ones I can
tell you this is she with the ugliest
woman around I would care for her just
the same please cylinder there's no
reason to be afraid until she runs away
I won't chase her I'm so sorry for what
happened many thanks and kind regards
Richard all right sounds like he's
pretty well settled by now yeah and
that's a good thing because a few days
later he went to see Linda and now we
turn the story up to 11.
on Thursday November 21st Linda was on
her way to the post office when Richard
appeared they spent most of the day
together and Richard confessed his love
for her Linda also had feelings for
Richard but she was married and had a
family she was conflicted though when he
kissed her she didn't resist yeah Oh
Linda got a groove back so they talked
about their childhoods things they had
in common Richard was very interested in
Linda's son Johnny he said he always
felt like he had a son even though he
didn't the following day Bud receives a
letter from Richard Jesus this guy get
paid by the letter or what Dear Mr
Hopkins the meeting yesterday between
Linda and I went very well she was very
relaxed and comfortable she sure was
stop it sorry Linda is a very
interesting person there's no wondering
why considering what she may be yes but
I believe that Linda is from another
place but Rey's here Richard gave an
update about Dan who had taken a turn
for the worse and was now in a mental
facility then Richard dropped the bomb
he said that since he was 10 years old
he had been dreaming about a girl he
felt like they grew up together Richard
and the girl didn't know each other's
name so they made up names he called her
baby Anne and she called him Mickey over
the years Richard's relationship
suffered because no matter who he dated
he only had feelings for Baby Anne who
he thought was a figment of his
imagination the older he got the more
Richard dreamed about baby Anne when
they were in their 20s they were in love
and wanted to spend the rest of their
lives together then he would wake up
Richard stopped dreaming of baby Anne
for 20 years then that early morning in
November 1989 he saw a baby Anne
hovering in a beam of blue light
Linda is my baby Anne she's real I came
away very angry that night after I left
her apartment it wasn't fair but I love
her soul but it's too late I've hinted
to Linda about a bond but she doesn't
remember Linda has me standing between
the fire and the water if I go in either
direction I'll burn or I'll drown
oh that was poetic I thought so too
so Bud asked Linda if she had any
imaginary friends when she was a child
she said yes his name was Mickey and now
that you mention it Mickey looked a lot
like Richard ew and so did her son
Johnny
[Music]
foreign
was shocked when she read Richard's
letter but she didn't want to get into
whether Richard was Johnny's father and
Bud didn't press the issue Richard
didn't involve himself in Linda's life
very much after that but she did receive
a creepy letter from Dan writing from a
mental institution by the time this
Christmas greeting reaches you I will
have managed to get out of this place
successfully would you believe I would
let you go so easy it seemed like
yesterday when I hated you until I think
about looking into those big deep brown
eyes he was then the hate goes away I
can't wait to watch you move as you walk
by I'm gonna inscribe our names with my
lips on that full heart-shaped mouth
Linda you don't belong here but I'll
find a place for you he goes on to say
that he's gonna take her somewhere far
away and that she'll make a beautiful
bride if you see Richard tell him I said
go to hell if I don't get out of here
I'll be thinking to you if I do I'll be
looking at you happy holiday pretty
Danny as far as We Know Dan never showed
up but Linda was paranoid for years and
as Linda's experiences finally tapered
off her son Johnny started talking about
weird dreams where little men would take
him to a round room and talk to him
without moving their lips I remember how
Linda said the aliens put something in
her nostril well whenever Johnny would
have these bad dreams he'd wake up with
a bloody nose
[Music]
well I told you this was a doozy this
story is basically a summary of Bud
Hopkins book witnessed the true story of
the Brooklyn Bridge UFO abductions I'll
put links below where you can buy the
book or read it online for free we only
scratched the surface
this oh yeah this book is over 400 pages
of interviews transcripts from hypnosis
sessions even pictures this has been
called the most important UFO case of
the 20th century
but is it true an article written by
investigators George Hansen Richard
Butler and Joseph stefila challenges the
story they interviewed Linda and did a
lot of legwork and say they've debunked
it I'll challenge their arguments and
see if we can figure out if the story is
true the first problem we have is that
the only Real Witness is Linda she's the
only person who saw Richard and Dan but
the tapes they sent that's right they
did send Bud audio tapes and other
people have heard those tapes same with
the woman whose car stalled on the
Brooklyn Bridge Janet Kimball people
have spoken to her and have seen her
speaking with bud
but handwriting analysis was done on her
letter and the handwriting is a match
for Linda's Linda also claimed her
cousin Connie was with her when someone
tried to kidnap her but asked to speak
to Connie a couple of days later Connie
called when Bud hung up the phone he had
a sour look on his face his wife asked
him what was wrong he said Linda just
called me pretending to be Connie we're
told that Secretary General de cuer met
with bud at O'Hare Airport and confirmed
the story though he wouldn't speak
publicly but nobody witnessed this
meeting and acquire's representatives
have said that he was home asleep that
night his office even issued a statement
forcefully denying anything like this
happened but what else is the Secretary
General of the United Nations gonna say
I was kidnapped by aliens woke up on a
beach saw the lady of the Sands and then
was being back to the roof of my car
well when you put it that way the story
starts to sound far-fetched plus the
actual way security and transport are
handled for a diplomat of this level is
not remotely close to what's described
in the book why didn't Linda report any
of this to the police she was kidnapped
multiple times assaulted almost killed
she feared for her safety and the safety
of her family but even Astrid to go to
the police she wouldn't when the other
investigators interviewed Linda and her
husband Steve Steve was very quiet he
had trouble answering a lot of the
questions but Linda would then jump in
to help him remember Steve left the
interview way early even though Linda
asked him to stay maybe it's unrelated
but their marriage didn't work out Linda
liked books about aliens and UFOs she
contacted Bud shortly after reading his
book Intruders and if her story sounds
like it came from a science fiction
novel that's because maybe it did
foreign
just a few months before Linda contacted
Bud Hopkins the Sci-Fi novel Night Eyes
was released there are some similarities
to Linda's case Linda was taken to a UFO
hovering over her high-rise apartment
building in New York City
Sarah was taken by a UFO hovering over
her high-rise apartment building in New
York City Dana Richard claimed to have
been on a Stakeout and were involved in
a UFO Abduction during early morning
hours the same thing happened to two
government agents in night eyes during
the kidnapping Dan took Linda to a safe
house on the beach during the kidnapping
and Night Eyes Derek took Wendy to a
safe house on the beach there are a few
other coincidences but some I think are
a stretch but these stood out to me as a
little too similar debunkers often bring
up that Linda's building is visible from
the loading dock of the New York Post at
3am the loading dock is packed with
dozens of workers loading trucks nobody
reported seeing a UFO or anything
strange but investigators only
interviewed the manager who spends a lot
of his shift indoors and while the dock
does have excellent visibility of
Linda's building the area where the
papers are being loaded you can't see
her building at all Bud said that in 10
years Linda's story never changed but
that's not true people who've seen her
speak at conventions said the details
have changed over time Linda claims she
would receive 50 of the book sales of a
movie deal or anything else that would
come from the story she later denied
this then she said she did say it but
she was intentionally lying then she
said she received a percentage but it
was just a token she described it but
that's true Linda got between 15 and 25
percent of the book the movie rights or
anything else that came from her story
but if Linda is perpetrating a hoax
she's got a lot of people involved but
Hopkins has multiple Witnesses on audio
tape and video and these have been
confirmed by other people but Linda has
made other wild claims like she said she
was abducted by aliens with John Gotti
Gambino family boss John Gotti he did
Dapper done the Dapper done she said
other crazy things like she might be
part alien her red blood cells are
Immortal she's descended from Joan of
Arc she was a professional singer in a
well-known pop band she said she met
with Cardinal O'Connor she was summoned
to a private meeting with the Pope she
said she was in World Trade Center on 9
11 when the planes hit but Hopkins knew
she made these claims but he chose to
leave them out of the book it's best not
to irritate a notorious Crime Boss hey
that's always good advice now supporters
of Bud Hopkins say he's a top-notch
investigator I disagree but only
interviewed and hypnotized people who
could support his premise in an alien
abduction Story the most important
people to speak to are the ones who can
disprove the story but didn't like to
speak to those people in fact when
dealing with the bunkers Bud would get
defensive and angry even Bud's wife
Carol felt his investigations lacked
objectivity what was important to Bud
was getting the story not necessarily
finding the truth he hated people
debunking his story so he wasn't going
to do it to someone else personally I
think Bud Hopkins was a compassionate
kind and empathetic person after all he
had a UFO Abduction support group
meeting in his house every week if you
made a claim that you were taken by
aliens Bud wanted to believe you he
wanted to help you I think his heart was
in the right place but that left him
impressionable was Linda hoaxing him for
attention for money she went from
housewife to rock star in the UFO
community and she loved the attention
now I know this story sounds crazy but
crazy doesn't mean false it's been 30
years and not a single person has come
forward claiming they were part of a
hoax but we have to admit the story it's
a lot all that comes down to Linda and
there's no middle ground either all this
happened or none of it so you're gonna
have to pick a side I've given you as
much information as I can and as always
what you believe is ultimately up to you
but whether you believe this story is
real or a hoax you can't be proved wrong
[Music]
thank you so much for hanging out with
me today my name is AJ that's hecklefish
this has been the y-files if you had fun
or learned anything do me a favor and
like subscribe comment and share that
stuff really helps the channel and like
most topics we cover on this channel
today's topic was recommended by you and
if there's a story you'd like to see or
learn more about go to the yfiles.com
tips a special thanks to our patrons who
make this channel possible without you
there would be no Wi-fi so thank you for
that and if you'd like to support the
channel consider becoming a member on
patreon it's as little as three dollars
a month or purchase something from the
Wi-Fi Store look if you don't have a
fear to crab Cat Coffee Mug it's time to
reevaluate your life that's gonna do it
until next time be safe be kind and know
that you are appreciated
[Music]
thank you